hello everyone and welcome to an
absolute thriller of a game from round
eight to defeat a candidate's tournament
2022 it's hikaru nakamura versus fabiana
carwana and this is one game that you
will
definitely want to close all your tabs
for uh before checking out you know you
do not want any distractions or
notifications during this one as it's uh
even though the first 20 moves of the
game are known theory and both fabiano
and hikaru just blitzed them out like
instantly uh still the game is uh
absolutely incredible and so much
happens in this game you will not uh you
you're not gonna believe this so uh not
uh to spoil anything let's dive straight
into it hikaru has the white pieces and
he opens with e4 we have e5 by fabi
knight to f3 knight to c6 and the bishop
to b5 going for the royal lopez and now
not a berlin but rather a6 fabi goes for
morphy's defense uh bishop to a for
knight to f6 and now that castles going
for the well-known knight captures on e4
the open spanish d4 uh we have b5
challenging the bishop bishop to b3 and
pawn to d5 so this has been played
millions and millions of times as i
always mention
d captures an e5 and the bishop to e6 so
nothing worth mentioning here we have c3
bishop to c5 putting pressure on the f2
pawn
but it doesn't really matter as the rook
defends the f2 pawn or or does it knight
the beat to d2 we have castles by fabi
and now that bishop the c2 putting more
pressure on the knight here and here
fabi just captures an f2 knight captures
on f2 giving up two pieces for the rook
and usually this isn't a good idea but
this position has been analyzed so
thoroughly that of course uh you know
that if one fabiana corona plays it in a
candidates tournament then you know it
is definitely uh legit so rook captures
bishop captures with czech king captures
and now pawn to f6 you're getting ready
to open up the f file for the black rook
uh knights to f1 again this is all very
well known so nothing new here f
captures on e5 and king the g1 getting
the king to safety and here we have
queen to d6 now interesting about this
position is that maksim vashila grav
already had this position against
fabiana corwana in this year's superbit
chess classic and fabiano lost this game
in that game against maxine vashila grab
fabiano played a queen to d7 but here he
improves with queen to d6 um
a a a very nice move that um uh well uh
he also played uh not only with the
black pieces but with the white pieces
as well but we're gonna get to that with
bishop to e3 by hikaru and then now
comes bishop to f5 now interestingly uh
karwana had this exact same position
with the white pieces against the jordan
found forest in this year's uh tata
steel tournament that ended in a draw
but in that game rook 8 to d8 was played
but here we have bishop to f5 this is
how fabiano improves on that game bishop
to b3 declining the trade putting the
bishop on this nice diagonal and now
rook 8 to d8
queen to e1 by hikaru and now knight to
a5 putting more pressure on this bishop
here and queen to f2 now putting
pressure on that c5 square uh and now
there is one game in the database that
reached this exact same position between
maria malika and may austin also was
played in this year uh where knight
captures some b3 was played you can
capture this um obviously as the the
knight here will guard the c5 square so
you don't have to worry about the nice
in between bishop c5 but here fabi just
goes knight to b7 and it is now as of
move 19 that we have a completely new
game so that's how uh the the open uh
spanish is uh
prepared and analyzed the first 20 moves
are usually just blitzed out and here we
have rook to e1 by hikaru pawn to c5 by
fabi and this is where things get really
really interesting so okay uh fabi gave
up two pieces for the rook but look at
his center he has all of these pawns
controlling all of these squares okay
bishop controls g4 that's not a pawn but
still incredible pressure and the the
absolute top move recommended by the
engine here is bishop to g5 and no doubt
this is what fabi was expecting and here
uh you know everything just completely
explode the the rook is attacked you
don't really get to move the rook
because if you move the rook then you
run into
all sorts of uh trouble uh yes you are
defending the e5 pawn but it doesn't
matter we can even just capture it uh if
recapture is bishop to f4 and it's not
very pleasant but the real idea behind
bishop g5
uh is that fabi can just give up the
rook on the eight play c4 after bishop
captures we're going to play c captures
on b3 and the once he carol moves the
bishop back we're going to create a pass
pawn here with b captures an a2 and
after rook to a1 we're gonna play bishop
to b1 trapping the rook on a1 and the
white will always be better here but
fabi has this analyzed hopefully hikaru
doesn't and that's why fabi plays it
however
hikaru doesn't play the absolute top
move recommended by the engine nor the
second move recommended by the engine
nor the third move recommended by the
engine but he plays a move that's not
recommended by the engine whatsoever and
that is knight to g3 and this is uh
where fabi really started thing and he
pretty much played it instantly
and it's uh unknown to us at least for
this moment uh hikaru will probably
mention in his analysis of the game uh
how he
came up with this idea was like a you
know really an over the board decision
or does he have it prepared because it
would be it would be incredible if he
would have in this variation on move 20
like the fifth engine move prepared
that's actually very strong but maybe
not as strong as the first four but you
know
nothing serious that fabi could take
advantage of it's hard to say we will
have to wait wait and figure this out
however
this is the first moment where fabi
paused and started thinking and
basically he has to decide what to do
with the bishop and he plays bishop to
d3 it makes sense you want to play e4
you want to keep the bishop on d3 of
course
now you're threatening just to win a
piece if e4 comes then the knight will
not be able to move so hikaru
immediately plays queen to d2 and now
fabi plays pawn to c4 and this is
already a second interesting decision as
e4 is very very
potent for example knight h4 g6 not
allowing any knights to come to f5 and
if bishop h6 we just play c4 incredible
stuff here once the bishop moves to d1
we're gonna play d4 uh the position
absolutely explodes and absolutely i
mean everything is possible here you
cannot uh you know claim who is better
here here the better player is the the
one who you know moves his pieces better
like it's a beautiful position uh but uh
instead we have c4 by fabi going after
the bishop right away and here hikaru
had like an hour and 55 minutes on the
clock so he did not spend any time
whatsoever and fabi already down to one
hour and 10 minutes uh bishop backed the
d1 by hikaru and now rook to d7
preparing to double up on the f file to
put more pressure uh and here uh again
fabi it took a lot of time to decide on
this uh on this move he's already below
the one hour mark he's now somewhere
around 59 minutes uh and uh hikaru plays
bishop to f2
this was an excellent moment for hikaru
to play b4 uh if you can throw in this
b4 you know without uh black being able
to exploit it then that's already
excellent of course the captures alpasan
is out of the question because the
bishop would hang but okay hikaru goes
for bishop to f2 and now rook uh
uh d to f7 uh like i said doubly gap idf
file and now knight to h1 a brilliant
defensive maneuver from hikaru the
knight is just nicely defending the
bishop on f2 and the the double rooks
aren't really posing any problems for
him so e4 the knight can now freely move
knight to d4 hikaru now down to an hour
and 30 minutes whereas fabi has some 40
minutes on the clock uh and now queen to
g6
again a very very interesting decision
by uh by fabi uh and what can hikaru do
here well he can pose a lot of problems
for fabi by playing h4 and now how can
fabi uh how can fabi play against this
h5 is obviously coming and uh does fabi
want to play h5 it's a very very
difficult move to play and the fabi is
burning so much time that you simply do
not have time to calculate h5 just to
give you a short example of what happens
after h5 uh queen g5 we offer a queen
trade and the queen trade is definitely
favoring hikaru here uh you kind of have
to capture here there's not all that
much you can do so captures captures
let's say pawn to g6 none knight the c6
and it's uh it's just a much better uh
position for white there's not all that
much to do the knight is coming to e5 so
let's say knight to d6 knight to e5 now
attacking the rook and the g6 pawn it's
uh very very
tough to play this now the only move
that keeps the position uh playable for
fobby is e3 but good luck finding that
from that position where you have to
decide whether to push h5 at all
rook captures on e3 and now rook to e7 i
mean what is this knight captures and g6
isn't really all that impressive you
have to play knight to f3 but just to
give you an example if knight captures
and g6 rogue captures an e3 knight
captures on f8 now we're gonna play rook
to e7 and the knight has no squares the
knight will be trapped uh the g6 square
is covered by the bishop so if bishop
captures an h5 we play king captures
here and now if bishop c5 we just move
the rook rook to d7 and the game
continues being pretty much equal
so uh it would be incredibly difficult
to calculate all of this but h5
definitely the move fabi has to play
here
fabi doesn't play it he plays knight to
c5 and now hikaru does not hesitate he
pushes h5 himself which doesn't seem to
be all that scary because i mean what is
really happening here we just move the
queen and that's it
well queen to d6 and now bishop to g4
hikaru finds uh
the only move that keeps the advantage
for white because what can uh what can
fobby play here hikaru has complete
control over the e6 square complete
control over the e3 square the knight
nicely covers the bishop here
and well fabi did sacrifice material for
the attack so where is this uh supposed
attack you can't move the knight because
then bishop e6 just wins the game uh how
do you approach this position he plays
h6 which is kind of the only useful move
you can make and now queen e3 by hikaru
just nicely improving the position now
uh maybe queen to h3 we're gonna win
that e6 square by force uh and fabi
decides all right we can't have that
queen to f4 he goes for a queen trade
and hikaru accepts this and it's very
interesting it's only moved 30 hikaru
has 55 minutes on the clock he uh
karwana has nine minutes on the clock
and hikaru goes for a queen trade and
this game is specifically
uh
even more interesting than it is because
hikaru uh
well he he missed many opportunities to
play much much better moves and this is
uh this is maybe one of them
because here after bishop to f5 uh now
you're just threatening to pick up the
queen and black doesn't really gain
anything from capturing here because
after counters and captures it's just
i mean white has a much better position
and uh trading queens does not help
black in any way you can't go for a
capture because after we capture the
knight will also be hanging and if you
let's say play rook to f6 uh because you
have to play something knight the g3
comes into the game and
of course hikaru will be much better
here so basically after bishop to f5
what you will have to do is queen e5 but
now bishop g3 we start improving our
position and it's just uh you know move
by move we claim more space and and just
to win a whole lot of material a queen
captures a queen capture sierra knight
to e7 with check now uh we win the
exchange because otherwise the queen
hangs so rook captures queen captures
and let's say queen captures an h5
bishop e5
and uh
i mean it's uh we're up a piece let's
not forget that uh well we also have
this incredible pressure black is not um
going to be able to defend all of the
threats here uh but okay hikaru traded
queens right away let's uh also remember
uh fabiano has nine minutes on the clock
to make 10 more moves and they have to
be incredibly precise rook captures on
f4 and now knight to e6 attacking both
rooks and the knight here so you have to
trade knight captures bishop captures
with king h7 and now bishop captures on
d5 eliminating the base of the pawn
chain and now the pawns are extremely
weak and this bishop here will not be
very bishopy it will basically be a pawn
for the rest of the game so rook eight
the uh f5 we have bishop to c6 by hikaru
not not going for the pawn because then
we can just push the pawn but rather
going for bishop to e8 if we defend this
pawn then fabi has no more counter play
so he has to capture it and not bishop
to d4 now just improving our position a
little by little so three more moves um
uh
before reaching time control uh and uh
well it's an incredibly tough position
for fobby so here we have rogue age back
to f5 fobby now down to two minutes two
and a half minutes on the clock and now
knight to f2 by hikaru uh you could also
play knight g3 but it's a forcing move
that will force fabi to move the rook by
playing knight to f2 i think hikar is
just um allowing uh fabi to spend more
time while still putting pressure on
this e4 pawn so at some point you you
will want to capture this uh and now
comes rook to f7
uh just uh you know
making a move he still needs to make
three more moves and with two minutes on
the clock that's not an easy thing to do
and now finally b4 from hikaru if you
can execute it now you should always do
it as it really uh
paralyzes uh fabi's entire queen side so
h5 by fabi and now comes pawn to a4 and
this was the first moment where not the
first moment but one of the moments that
i've mentioned where hikaru just could
have ended the game on the spot uh h4 is
a terrible blunder by fabi and you
exploited by playing bishop to e8 we
just captured this pawn he blundered it
and that's it i mean we were winning now
with one extra pawn we are much more
winning there's no good move here after
the rook moves we can just capture the
pawn and that's it we have the exact
same position we're just up one pawn
another thing you could do is just grab
this pawn that you've
so conveniently attacked so many times
knight captures bishop captures the
knight captures and again not all that
much to do but by playing a4 which is uh
which is a strong move but it allows
fabita remain in the game b captures on
a4 bishop captures an a4 and now pawn to
h4 now fabi's creating some threats here
if he pushes h3 uh could be could be
very interesting uh and hikaru goes
bishop to e3 now attacks the rook rook
back to f5 and now uh rook to a1 so this
already moved 42 time control has been
reached and the players now have
additional time
but now fabi plays h3 and this is such a
beautiful move uh that uh
well really really got hikaru thinking
and i think you will also enjoy it if
you if you give it a few seconds and try
to find the only winning idea for hikaru
here while i give you a couple of
seconds because it's just amazing
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on not capturing the
pawn with the pawn or with the knight
because that doesn't work and for those
of you who found rook to a2
congratulations as this is an incredible
incredible move to spot just to give you
an example why if you capture with the
pawn then rook f3 is the idea that's why
you can't play this you we attack the
bishop here and if rook to e1 let's say
you defend the bishop rook g3 check king
h2 and now you just pick up the bishop
that's defending the knight that's the
problem rook captures rook captures with
check and that's it now you are no
longer winning this position and
capturing uh uh with uh
uh with the
uh knight isn't much better if you
capture with the knight then we trade
rooks rook f1 check rook captures rook
captures with czech king h2 and now rook
to e1 again kicking away the bishop
winning the e3 square once the bishop
moves we kick it again and now e3 is
coming for example bishop somewhere e3
and the black spawns are marching
forward so this spawn uh this rocket you
move is the only move that
still uh keeps the game winning for
hikaru because also one of the threats
here is just h2 i mean look at this we
can capture here bishop captures we play
h2 check you have to capture it and then
the the other rook captures uh uh
the night back so we win back the two
pieces for our rook so here rook a2 by
hikaru again played it fairly quickly h
characters on g2 and now another unique
move that hikaru had to find in order to
continue the game properly because here
if you capture again rook f3 is
extremely strong going after the bishop
bishop to d1 blocking this rook's
approach to f3 and now again fabi is
struggling to find moves here he plays
rook to f6 he just defends the pawn but
now bishop g4 going after the rook rook
to d5 now king captures on g2 we
eliminate this pawn and we no longer
have to worry about it rogue g6 attacks
the bishop king g3 we have bishop to f1
and now comes bishop
bishop the d4 not rushing anything not
going after the uh pawn here because
here the tactics just work in fabie's
favor uh your knight is saying if you
move night the bishop is hanging if you
defended it then everything is hanging
just captures captures captures and
you've thrown the game away so bishop to
d4 uh beautiful move uh just you know
centralizing the bishop and uh
taking away squares from fabi's rooks
bishop to d3 and now king to f4
improving the
position of the king king the g8 and now
bishop to f5 attacking the rook
rook to h6 and now knight to g4 just
winning more squares attacking the rook
rook back to d6 and now knight to e3
attacking this rook rook to b5 and now
bishop to c5 again winning even more
squares rook to f6 and now king the e5
look at this beautiful king just you
know marching his way all the way to the
to the other half of the board king to
f7 and now comes knight to d5 and this
knight to d5 is maybe the third move in
the game where hikaru rushed a little
bit as he could have ended the game
right away with rook to f2 there there
is no move basically fabi can play now
you are threatening bishop to e6 and
it's game over there's really no good
good way of defending this but he plays
knights to d5 which is seemingly the
same thing but now fabi can again
give up some material and continue the
game rook captures an f5 with czech king
captures and now e3 opening up a
discovery here king to e5 and now pawn
to e2 so hikaru still winning here but
fabi with the past pawn on e2
bishop to f2 guarding d1 square now
comes rook to b8 now we want to go all
the way around uh guard e1 square and
fabinho wants to promote his pawn so
bishop to e1 we have rooked the e8 with
check and now comes king to f4 another
move uh that hikaru played pretty much
instantly the where where again uh king
to d4 is just uh uh so much stronger as
there really isn't a move you can play
if rook t for czech king the c5 now
there's no way a good way to continue
this if rook to e6 you defend the a6
pawn knight to c7 we attack the rook we
go after the pawn and after another
check king d4 rookie for checking d5 now
you're out of checks you're gonna push
this pawn we're gonna capture on a6 and
the the position is winning however
after king to f4 he gave fabi another
shot at uh at saving the game and fabi
takes it almost immediately he plays g5
with check and this is such an important
tempo
having the pawn not on g7 but rather on
g5
that it might definitely influence the
race because of course you cannot
capture if you capture rookie five check
just picks up the knight so king to g3
this is uh uh this square is much less
active than
where hikaru's king previously was and
you know where it would be on d4 and now
comes rook to e6 and this is where uh
fabi fabi misses it here okay fabio was
again low on the clock but rook the e5
is is incredibly strong and um uh it
would be very very difficult to play
this the knight is hanging and once you
move the knight we're going to play rook
f5 now going for rook to f1 and once you
capture this and rook to f1 is played
rook to a1 guarding the bishop and now
king to f6 you get this position where
it's not going to be easy to uh to look
for chances here right it's just a very
very very tricky position probably with
perfect play you can win this but this
was fabi's best chance if i played rook
to e6 instead of e5 he defended the pawn
but now there is no good way to
get the rook to f1 he will have to go
all the way around but
well easier said than done hikaru plays
king f2 we have rook to h6 and now king
the e3 hoping for rook to h1
uh so he can play king to d2 to defend
the bishop this way but fabio repeats
rook to a6 check king to f2 and now rook
to h6 again not going for this um king
to d2 move now uh because if after this
rook to e6 check you go to d2 then we
play rook d6 and again you've uh you've
blundered the game if to a5 guarding
then i just bash a p4 we go after the
knight and now this is a big problem so
instead we have king back to f2 and
fabio repeats rook to h6 uh hoping to
to claim a draw here where uh hikaru uh
has given fabi so many opportunities to
bonds back but now hikaru goes again for
the only winning idea and that is knight
to e3 and this is such a difficult
maneuver to spot you have to play knight
e3 bring the knight to the g2 move the
bishop from e1 put the knight on e1 and
your position will then and only then be
winning and still if uh with perfect
play from fabi it's it's uh
well
you you have to be a magician to win
this he car uh fabi played rook to f6
and this allows hikaru to win the game
very easily but after rook to h2 the
game would not be easy at all okay we
play night knight to g2 to defend the
bishop rook h3 now this is how we defend
we keep the king here not allow the king
any squares and after rook to a5 going
after our pawn we're going to push pawn
to g4 if king g1 now we play rook to f3
and it's uh it's still very very hard to
win this for example bishop d2 we play
rook f1 check if king h2 rook to d1
uh very very very tricky stuff if if now
rook to a2 we play bishop the b1 and not
rook to b2 and you get the disposition
where again okay you will win this with
white but it's it's such a scary
position that uh
yeah the the this game definitely
deserves to be in the candidates
tournament but fabi uh rushed it with
rook to f6 as he was again very low on
the clock now king to g3 we have rook to
f1 but now just knight to g2 so this is
much different than the position we
discussed uh rook back to f6 and now
bishop to f2 now the knight is coming to
e1 king to g6 we have rook to a5 and now
rook to e6
we have knights to e1 now now blockading
d1 square and now bishop to f5 we have
knight to f3 by hikaru and now rook to
d6 we have knight to d4 now not allowing
the the rook to be activated bishop to
d3 defending the e2 pawn and now rook to
e5 going after the e2 pawn king to f6
and now knight to f3 anyways in this
position on move 74 uh after all of this
has been done that finally fabiana
carwana resigned in the game and hikaru
nakamura gets his second victory in the
candidates tournament which brings him
to a total of plus one
and this was this knight to f3 move was
already played after six hours of
excruciating play and uh fabi fabi had
enough here because now hikaru is
covering all of the squares there is
absolutely no move fabi can make and uh
well
there's just no point in trying uh the
only thing you could do is maybe offer a
rook trade but hikaru happily trades as
you know he is up a piece uh so so
there's that
uh incredible incredible stuff by hikaru
so basically what happened in this game
uh fabi who is uh one of the most
prepared players in the world got out
prepared by hikaru now the only question
is did hikaru out prepare him uh not at
home but actually did he call just uh
you know destroy fabi's entire
preparation uh
with this knights the g3 move over the
board that that's the real question if
that's the case then uh i mean that's
incredible stuff from hikaru
because you you can be absolutely sure
fabio was prepared for the absolute top
engine moves here like like we said
bishop g5 queen to g3 queen to d2 but he
carves knight g3 uh fabi was not
prepared and he started burning a lot of
time just for his next two moves he
wasted over an hour and uh well it was
just not enough to
at the tackle all the all the game had
to offer and uh even though hikaru gave
him a lot of chances to at the bounce
back into the game uh in the end he car
was victorious and what does this mean
for the standings we're gonna show the
standings after we show one more uh game
from round round eight but basically now
with fabi who was trailing uh by half a
point uh uh to the leader nippomashi uh
is now down a full point behind behind
yanni pomeshi india drew his game today
uh so he is definitely the clear leader
but hikaru now with plus one also uh is
very very very close to the leader so
one and a half point away from uh from
niponishi and as nippo still has to face
fabi in the second half of the
tournament and nakamura will also get
his chance against nepal uh pretty much
everything is still possible and
nakamura gets one step closer to
challenging magnus carlsen for the world
chess championship title if magnus you
know decides to play in the end uh but
you know if he car wins i'm pretty sure
magnus will
will play uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it sorry for a bit
of a longer video but uh this i i'm
pretty sure this was the the absolute
most exciting game of the
of the of the tournament it had so many
ups and downs so many you know if you
made a series on these this game it had
it would have like the three or four
seasons it's you know absolutely
spectacular game uh so yeah we really
hope you guys enjoyed it i would like to
wish a very happy birthday to thomas
mumford and i would like to thank and it
was in this position that austin had a
birthday david kimura brian tremper and
stephen mcneil for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
candidates uh until it finishes so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day